i mean i don't know you well but i think
you're probably doing better than you're
giving yourself credit for it be my
guess because you've done some pretty
awesome stuff in your life and i'm sure
a lot of it's been intuitive you might
guess
um but it sounds like what you want to
do because you're obviously into high
performance you want to get better at it
but i don't i don't know if you're not
good at it i don't know if i would if i
could let it go that far uh if i may be
so bold um
but um like i was talking with leanne
rimes like two weeks ago
and uh she's amazing and she was like
she was like yeah just like in like the
last like two years i feel like i'm
stepping in my purpose i was like whoa
slow down girl like
you're leanne rimes like you're an icon
and like in the last two years
you started to step in your purpose like
can we just like pause on that and
acknowledge how epic that is like holy
cow what have you been doing this whole
time like oh my god i can't even imagine
what's next
right um it's just i think pausing on
some of those moments sometimes can be
very powerful and very important
and my hunch is that you have uh really
good finely tuned intuitive skills but
what i can tell you is
that um
like let's just practice for a second
right has there ever been a time in your
life where you had this very clear yes
that like yes this is what i'm supposed
to do and like it's like so clear to me
okay and do you know what that feels
like in your body
clear mm-hmm yeah okay and then have you
ever had a time where it's such a
obvious no you're like
oh no that is not for me
yeah okay and you know what that feels
like
mm-hmm so
yeah so that's the baseline right you
want to start there like you already
know what it feels like to have a yes
and a no right
then it's about understanding this is
that this is the hard part when you're
making intuitive first of all people say
i want to be more intuitive it's like
no
you want different intuition
because like no they want they want to
intuit something differently meaning
like they don't like the intuition that
they're getting they want to be a
different intuition because everybody's
interested problem is that your
intuition sometimes goes ooh shiny
things go there and you're like that
feels so good and then it's like oh
intuition's like get out of that
relationship or like quit that job and
you're like whoa i mean that's probably
not true i probably just need to try
harder
whatever like you go to that that
intuition yeah but but intuition is not
discretionary between like what you
think you what you as you're like the
place in this world is right now what
you want it's more about the long game
right so definitely your higher self and
your you know potentiality in a way that
you could never understand and so you
know the no's are just as progressive
just as great as oh definitely 100 and
like here's the thing and uh i don't
know if i have any data on this that i
can cite so i'm just going to tell you
this is anecdotal
but what i've seen in my own life and
with our clients it's anecdotal okay
it's anecdotal meaning like for people
what's anecdotal it's just observed it's
not verified through peer-reviewed
research okay
um
when you
get enough interception meaning
awareness of your internal mechanisms
and all your emotions right and you
start to make contact with your most
traumatized parts and like start to like
love them and surface then make them
more explicit share them through
relationship they start to feel better
over time
on the other side of that part kind of
being i for lack of a word like pulled
out of purgatory right
like that is your direct connection to
spirit right there
right like that part is also your direct
connection to your intuition into spirit
and so what can feel like intuition can
sometimes be
a dissociated trauma response and like a
subtle underneath that is what the
intuition is but it can very very some
very similarly the part that's most
traumatized is usually the part that's
most sensitive to intuition too um and
so when you can help that part become
more explicit and more regulated um and
then you start to listen to it because
that's the whole point of an illness
right as we were talking earlier about
is like to listen to your body when you
can actually listen to the part that was
suicidal or
super angry or depressed and you can
start to improve your relationship with
those parts and go what are you what are
you what are you trying to tell me right
now right
and then you're like oh i should leave
this relationship right and mine's like
kind of like right here on my left side
uh that's why i'm doing that right
that's where i feel it and this is also
the part that gets activated when i feel
super abandoned right i'm like all right
man what do you need right i need a hug
okay cool let's get a hug right um and
but the intuition is also right there
too um and so they can be very finely
married but at the same time if you can
anchor into like remembering what the
yes was and what the note was it can be
very helpful as well but
usually an intuitive choice
is
like co-occurring with
absolute fear
because it usually brings you more into
the mystery of life and less into the
certainty of life right um and so it can
feel
very
um
i don't know strange in fact i just
relocated to los angeles and like this
field this felt like a crazy choice to
me for a long time i had to check in
with like
15 people
and i never overthink things right and i
was saying with my therapist who's like
was trained by milton erickson like
she's like top top top therapist she's
incredible and i was like
am i crazy am i can you please tell me
if i'm like bipolar or crazy or like
psychotic right now and she's like went
down the list she's like no i think
you're making a really good choice and i
was like but it feels awful she's like
actually mastin
usually you go so fast that you don't
feel your feelings right and you end up
maybe not making the best choice what
you're doing now is you're going slower
feeling your feelings
and it's actually a better choice
because you're so in touch with your
feelings and i was like wait wait wait
so what's wrong is right
and what's right is wrong she's like
basically right i was like oh my god i
hate this
i hate this so much right